thanks Magnus thanks to all the members
of the committee and thanks for that
great introduction
so I've I've been interested in
gravitational waves for a long tono so I
I began this inquiry really with a
series of stories stories and thought
experiments and I thought what I would
do in the lecture today is give you a
sense of the path of behavioral
economics how it started from these
stories and thought experiments and we
will end up with the Swedish Social
Security system which is another
experiment so maybe my most famous story
involves a dinner party and a bowl of
cashew nuts this was back when I was in
graduate school a bunch of economists
were coming over for dinner we put out a
bowl of cashews and serve drinks and
after a while about half the bowl had
been consumed we were worried about our
appetites and so I took the bowl and hid
it in the kitchen and I think came back
and first of all everybody thanked me
thank God you got rid of those nuts and
then since it was a group of economics
graduate students we began to analyze it
which shows you the danger of going to a
dinner party with a group of economists
and so the the analysis was a that we
were happy and B that we were not
allowed to be happy because it's a basic
axiom of economics that more
choices are always preferred to fewer
and before we had the choice to eat the
nuts or not and now we didn't so what
were we doing being happy so how is it
that having a choice removed can make us
better off this led to a series of
papers with my friend here schefren
self-control my second story involves
the then chairman of the Economics
Department at the University of
Rochester where I was studying who I
followed in his footsteps
in becoming a wine lover and so when I
met him he had been collecting and
drinking wine for a long time
and had made some wise purchases early
on possibly including even this bottle
but for this story we're gonna say he
bought a bottle for $4.95 and later was
able to sell it for $100 and he had a
rule that he wasn't willing to pay more
than $30 for a bottle of wine but he
sometimes would drink one of his old
bottles well that's a puzzle if you're
an economist he won't buy he won't sell
but he will drink so that's kind of the
economists reaction to this and that
story eventually led to another research
stream on what we'll call the endowment
effect loss aversion status quo bias and
so forth here's a third story these are
all from the same vintage kind of when I
was in grad school
a friend and I were given tickets to a
basketball game in Buffalo we were
living in Rochester there was a big
snowstorm and we wisely decided not to
go to the game but my friend said had we
bought those tickets we would have been
we would go to that game now of course
the economists call this the sunk cost
fallacy and the question is why would
anybody think going to the game helps so
yes in that hypothetical where we had
paid a lot of money for these tickets
there would be that wasted money but
going to the game wasn't gonna get that
money back so why is it that there was
this temptation to feel like we should
go to the game if we had paid for the
tickets and this and many other stories
led to a research program on mental
accounting so I then met these two guys
these two young handsome guys here Amos
Tversky and Daniel Kahneman and I got an
idea from them the kind of that made my
research possible they were busy
studying how people make judgments this
is before they wrote their famous paper
on prospect theory and the idea related
to earlier work by herb Simon it says
okay people how are boundedly rational
and so they use simple rules of thumb to
help them make decisions and then here
was the aha moment I got from reading
their research which is that the use of
these heuristics not only leads to
errors economists would have no problem
with that we know how to add an error
the idea was that they would lead to
systematic bias so an example is you can
ask people what do they think is the
ratio of gun deaths by homicide to gun
deaths by suicide in the United States
people think homicides are much more
frequent cause of death in fact suicides
are about twice as often that's an
example of what they call the
availability bias and it's just you can
you can win bar bets based on their
research so one lesson from these
stories is that there's a bunch of
things that economic theory tells us we
can leave out and in fact makes the
strong prediction that they simply will
not matter I call these supposedly
irrelevant factors and really my
research can be summarized as there are
a lot of these supposedly irrelevant
factors that are not irrelevant they
matter so I call these sifts supposedly
irrelevant factors so my three little
stories illustrate them if you push the
cashews just even to the other side of
the table as we've all done on occasion
you know maybe with the prior of the
delicious bread they insist on giving
you in Swedish restaurants we pushing
you to the other side of the table can
help why in the world should that help
you can reach over there and get it the
location of the bread is as if the fact
that professor rosette owned that bottle
of wine is as if his willingness to
drink it should not depend on whether he
owns it assuming he can buy and sell at
the same price and the sunk cost is
another sip how much we paid for the
tickets should
affect our decision to go to the game so
once we realize that there's this long
list of sifts we can expand the
predictive power of economic theory
because a lot more stuff matters so how
do we get from stories to science I'm
gonna illustrate that with one
experiment that I did with my friends
Daniel Kahneman and Jack connect and
you'll see the the mug here is place a
crucial role in this my last remaining
mug is now in the Nobel Museum so I
stole these Legos from my grandchildren
and you'll see they're gonna play a
crucial role in in this little
illustration so here's how the
experiment works we start using a
technique that was invented by Vernon
Smith who shared the Nobel Prize with
Danny Kahneman fifteen years ago and in
using Vernon Smith's technique we assign
values to people so we do that by saying
if you end up with one of these tokens
at the end of the experiment you can
redeem it for the value indicated here
then we assign tokens at random which
we've done here and incidentally my
friend linea who produced all these
beautiful slides has assigned these at
random in the way that condiment and
Tversky would say is the most random
looking way of a random
the assigning took nicely done Linea so
we've assigned these at random and now
we conduct a market in which we allow
people to trade so people who don't have
tokens can buy them people who have
tokens can sell them and then we see
what happens and this is what happens
which is exactly what is supposed to
happen and this is an example of what's
called the Coase theorem named after
Ronald Coase in 1991 Nobel laureate his
basic idea is that in a market where
transaction costs are low as they are in
this experiment then the initial
assignment of property rights which in
this case was done at random will not
affect the eventual allocation of
resources and we see that's true here
the people the guys the Legos on the top
row who really love tokens end up with
all the tokens okay
now we have the Legos back and here the
values we've now arranged the Legos in
the order in which they like a Cornell
coffee mug so that guy in the left
really wants one of those mugs it's
worth twenty dollars to him whereas
whoever that guy is in the bottom right
Wood has no interest in a Cornell mug
maybe it doesn't like Cornell or it
doesn't love coffee or what-have-you
so now we're gonna do the same random
assignment coincidentally just the same
way in the very random looking
assignment and now we're gonna do a
another market just the way we did with
tokens
and if the Coase theorem worked again
the people who love the mugs most would
end up with all the mugs what actually
happened well we got about a third as
much trading as we should have and the
reason for that was that the people who
had mugs didn't want to give them up but
the people who didn't have mugs were not
that interested in buying one so what
did we learn from this two things one is
we can't learn much about human behavior
by running experiments in which we
assign values to people because that's
not the way life works when we go into
the market there's nobody telling us
what we should pay for that loaf of
bread or that bundle of Swedish
meatballs and when we deal with the real
world then we observe two little trading
why well it's kind of over determined
part of it is loss aversion the idea
that it hurts more to give something up
than to acquire it and there's also
something called status quo bias which
we will see again later where people
tend to stick with whatever they have
and there are other factors that are
reinforcing these we know what we have
and we kind of like it and something
else
we're not sure what what we would get
and then there's just our basic laziness
that the sort of thing that when we're
watching television we can find
ourselves watching the show that comes
on on the same station we've been
watching
even though the cost of switching is
exactly one thumb click so as Magnus
mentioned one of the questions we asked
in behavioral economics is what happens
if we relaxed assumptions of unlimited
rationality and unlimited willpower so
we deal with humans and suppose that
these humans are not all as smart as
Einstein and don't have perfect
self-control they're more like Homer
Simpson then what well let's take
another Nobel prize-winning theory this
one from Franco Modigliani that's called
the life cycle hypothesis this is the
standard economic model of saving for
retirement so let me just illustrate how
that's supposed to work it's basically
two steps first figure out how much you
expect to make over your lifetime how
long you're gonna live then decide how
you'd like to smooth consumption over
that lifetime and then do it so here's
an illustration here's a very simple
case suppose your income is going to
steadily increase until you reach 65 at
which point you retire and stop earning
money and suppose you wanted to have a
perfectly flat consumption profile then
you would borrow early in your life you
would save later in your life and then
you would just save and you would when
you were 20
you would formulate that plan and then
you would do it now of course life is
more complicated than that
for example income might have unexpected
changes so oops you get laid off and you
go to Silicon Valley and make a bundle
of my UPS there's a the startup doesn't
do so well but then you write them then
you write a book so you know that that's
those are income surprises we can have
consumption surprises that sports car
was irresistible kids move back in kids
don't even think about it
maybe the grandchildren they're cute but
then you know you get old and all kinds
of stuff happens that you don't
anticipate so you can see this is hard
and so people might need some help
and the econ's in economic theory don't
need any help they can just figure all
this out they can figure out what they
need to do and they don't have any
self-control problems so they just do it
now this is a new problem that humans
face we've been around for millions of
years they tell us and for most of our
time on earth saving for retirement was
not something anyone needed to worry
about the reason is you would die first
so those that did manage to live long
enough to be able to stop working the
solution was move in with their kids who
conveniently were living next door and
still were willing to have their parents
move in and then in the 20th century
these norms started to break down the
kids moved away parents started living
longer
and so we had to solve this problem and
some of the solutions the early
solutions were things like social
security systems and companies
sponsoring defined benefit pension plans
and those are the old plans where what
you you got an annuity based on how long
you worked and what you made and these
plans were very easy for us humans
because there were no choices
you just you got taxed on your income
and then you got your Social Security
payments the same with your job you
worked there were you there were this
the retirement was all in the background
and then when you retired you got this
annuity and life was easy
well firms and countries discovered that
especially pay-as-you-go pension plans
can lead to problems and so they created
new strategies called defined
contribution plans and in these are much
harder for humans humans have to decide
whether to join the plan and then if
they join how much to save and then if
they and then how to invest that money
and some people don't bother to join
those who join may not save enough or
may not invest particularly wisely
and notice that the traditional model is
of no help whatsoever in solving this
problem because it assumes people have
solved it and if they're not saving
enough well that's because they don't
expect to live very long or are happy
not having very much when they retire so
if they're just saving the right amount
you have no advice to give them and and
there's no reason to offer them help so
how can behavioral economics help well
one way is using what Cass Sunstein and
I refer to as choice architecture so
choice architecture is the environment
in which we make decisions so one
example is a menu if you go to a
restaurant the chef has decided what he
or she wants to cook but there's
somebody at the restaurant whose job is
to write that down into a menu and it
could be a simple menu you can have a
four-course or a six-course dinner and
you have no choices or it could be you
know one of these menus at a Chinese
restaurant that seems to be endless and
so one lesson from
Averill economics is that what you order
will depend on the structure of the menu
and in an Italian restaurant if the
pasta courses are in a separate category
people will order differently than if
they are mixed in with the other
appetizers or entrees store layouts
again if you assume people just go to
the store and buy the optimal bundle
then the way the store is arranged won't
matter it'll be another SIF
but stores have learned that's not right
and they spend a lot of money figuring
out how they want you to walk through a
supermarket and make sure you pass by
the things that are most profitable and
they stick things like milk in the back
of the store because that's the thing
you buy most often and you're be sure to
walk by a lot of tempting other things
when you go by places like Amazon of
course
I've spent billions thinking about
choice architecture so one of the
lessons of choice architecture and the
title of the book Cass and I wrote is
that the choice architecture can
influence what we pick because it will
include what we call nudges so what are
nudges dodges are features of the
environment that influence the behavior
of humans but would not influence the
behavior of econ so we're an item is on
the menu doesn't affect Homo economicus
but it does affect us so the feature of
nudges that we stress in our book is
that nudges are a way to influence
choices without forcing anyone to do
anything
and we called the philosophy we espoused
libertarian paternalism many people did
think this phrase was an oxymoron we
wrote a paper called libertarian
paternalism is not an oxymoron a law
professor wrote another paper saying
libertarian paternalism is an oxymoron
I was lobbying with gas that we should
write a rejoinder that says no it's not
Reason prevailed so what are some nudges
maybe the most powerful nudge we have in
our arsenal is simply to change the
default so what what is the default the
default is simply what happens if you do
nothing now we're really good at doing
nothing passivity is one of humans
greatest skills so an application of
this idea in the domain of pension plans
is what's come to be known as automatic
enrollment so in the old system when you
were first eligible for the pension plan
you there were a bunch of forms you had
to fill out and you'd have to decide how
much to save and then how to invest
there could be a big long pile of these
forms some people like my friend castes
are very norm averse forum averse and if
caste has to fill out a form
he's almost certain not to do it so what
does automatic enrollment do it says you
get the same pile of forms but on the
top page it says if you don't fill these
forms out we will enroll you in the
pension plan at this saving rate and in
this fund and you don't have to do
anything so that's a SIF right the
default is this if it takes a minute or
two to fill out these forms so it
shouldn't matter does it matter yes big
time so this is some data from Vanguard
that administers thousands of these
plans the purple lines are the
percentage of people that are enrolled
for plants that use automatic enrollment
the gray lines are for those that don't
and you can see for any income group
about 90% of the people join if we use
automatic enrollment much less for other
groups particularly for lower income
groups so this this is this is a nudge
that's particularly effective at helping
lower-income people save for retirement
well there's a problem with automatic
enrollment
and that is that particularly in the
United States the firms that employ this
strategy almost universally enroll
people at too low of a level often 3% of
income that is not enough to save for
retirement so how can we solve this
problem my former students loma been
artsy and i took this on and what we
decided to do is think about this
starting with the psychology and and ask
well what is it that's preventing people
from saving enough well one is self
control problems we can go out for a
fancy dinner tonight that's tempting
we're are saving for retirement that's
some time off in the future and we know
people have more self control for the
future then for now many of us are
planning diets not this week certainly
maybe after the new year
the second is loss aversion that i've
previously mentioned people don't like
to see their income go down so we wanted
to take that into consideration and then
inertia people are good at doing nothing
so our idea was we know these things are
preventing people from saving let's flip
the problem around and use those to
create a plan that will take those
weaknesses if you want to call it that
and use them to help so the plan we
created who we called save more tomorrow
and the basic idea was to invite people
now to save more later
because self-control is easier for later
it's like the our diet plan that will
start in January and particularly to
invite them to save more when they get
their next raise so they won't see their
income go down that will eliminate the
loss aversion and then we're gonna keep
that up until they hit some goal so
we'll get inertia working for us so we
spent years trying to get any company to
try this and we finally found one in
Chicago and in this particular
implementation the company it was a
small company they hired a financial
advisor and offered his services to any
employee it was about 300 employees and
for most of them he the advisor said we
think you should save at least five
percentage points more and most of the
employees said that you're nuts I can't
afford that so then and only then were
they offered the same or tomorrow plan
and it was a quite an aggressive one
they're saving was increased by three
percentage points every time they got a
raise so notice this is all a SIF right
with life cycle savers a they would have
no interest in joining save more
tomorrow because they're already saving
the right amount and if it was put in
they would undo it because they are
already saving the right amount so so it
shouldn't work a no one should join and
be their behavior won't change well
let's see what happened the first line
of this chart are the people who said
they didn't want to talk to this
financial advisor and you can see
the inertia in this system these numbers
fluctuate a little it's not that anyone
is doing anything it's in there's
attrition so we some people leave the
company then here is the group that took
the advice to go up by five percentage
points you can see they did that and
then stopped then here are our guys and
you can see we almost quadrupled saving
rates using supposedly irrelevant
factors now a question we asked and we
were asked at hundreds of workshops yes
but maybe you get them to save more over
here
but then they're undoing it somewhere
else that you can't see and for 30 years
or so I was trying to figure out how to
test and possibly reject this
alternative hypothesis I never could
find the data that would allow me to do
that
fortunately in Scandinavia there are no
secrets and so the great young economist
rush Shetty and some colleagues were
able to test this hypothesis in nearby
Denmark and here's essentially what they
did they looked at people who switched
jobs where their pension contributions
went up by at least three percentage
points and you can see what happens to
their pension saving it goes up and they
write so this is people being passive
the way we've seen in the other things
I've shown you so far but what are they
doing in their other behavior
here's their company pensions nothing
here's their other saving nothing so no
we're not stealing from some other pot
it's all net saving okay let me end with
some new research I've been doing with
two of my former students Henrik
cronquist who's Swedish and Frank you
who's not this is a multinational team
and it involves as the locals may know
in 2000 Whedon introduced something they
called the premium pension system and it
has the following key features there's a
16% payroll tax that goes to fund Social
Security 2.5 percent is directed toward
this new premium pension system there
were four hundred and fifty options in
this plan essentially any mutual fund
approved by the EU that wanted to get in
was allowed in now when it was launched
the system had two nudges now they
weren't called nudges because we hadn't
coined that term yet but they were not
just nonetheless so nudge number one was
there was a default if you didn't fill
out a form then you would be given this
default fund with the spiffy title a p7
and so anybody who didn't want to make a
choice was in that fund and then some
people who
attractive and was actually a pretty
well-designed fund with low fees they
would also get that that choice that
fund has done pretty well so all the
economists I know here claim they
actively picked it I want to tell those
people we now have your data so we're
gonna be checking so we're gonna call
these delegate errs they delegate their
investment decisions to the people at a
p7 nudge number two and this one is a
bit curious the government decided that
in spite of creating this 13 basis point
globally diversified fund really people
should choose their own portfolios from
this array of 450 funds and they
launched a big advertising campaign
saying choose for yourself it's your
duty as a Swedish citizen to create the
best possible portfolio so the
government advertised that was the
largest advertising campaign in Swedish
history it was supplemented by funds
advertising as well saying yes choose
for yourself and in particular choose
our fund these ads were not particularly
informative here's here's one
so Indiana Jones thinks you should
invest in whatever this fund is it's
kind of a scary picture I'm not my wife
used to teach advertising I don't know
whether she would approve of this ad but
anyway there were those ads and so what
happened we have a battle of the nudges
the default versus the urging which one
our Theory doesn't tell us anything
about that but the the ad campaign won
so 2/3 of Swedish citizens decided to
form their own portfolios the rest took
the default now since then new people
entered the system mostly young people
entering the workforce for the volta
first time or immigrants the advertising
campaigns stopped both the government
and the funds stopped advertising and
there were some lingering effects of
those some people are joining just a
month after the campaign ended but then
it wore out and here's what happened so
you can see this is year one when two
thirds of the people chose their own
portfolios that tapered off and in
recent years almost no one is choosing
their own portfolio those numbers on the
right are about half a percent so that's
kind of interesting right so
but one of the questions we're
interested in is well how long do not
just last right so those guys on the
left were well actually until 2008 they
were locked in there was an obscure rule
the justification of which no one has
been able to explain to me but if you
maybe somebody here knows but if you
turn down the default fund you weren't
allowed to take it later until 2008 then
they changed that rule but so one of the
question is those guys who were nudged
to be individualistic did they stay that
way and if so that'd be interesting
because almost no one has chosen to do
that since so 27 percent of the people
in the default fund have left and
decided to become do-it-yourselfers
but essentially no one that started as
into it yourselfer has switched their so
this nudge has lasted more or less
forever and that's in spite of the fact
that the default fund has had drastic
changes so in 2010 the managers of the
fund decided they wanted to juice the
returns well hopefully so they decided
to add leverage you know what does that
mean technically they were borrowing and
buying options but the details of that
are not important you they initially had
a hundred and twenty five percent
leverage meaning
that if the market went up 10% the fund
would go up 12 then they switch to 50%
leverage so 50 percent leverage means
that if the market goes up 10% you go up
15% but if the market Falls 10% the fund
Falls 15% now in hindsight these guys
look like geniuses since the market has
pretty much steadily gone up since they
took these but we can ask what would
happen if we had another financial
crisis so what would this fund have done
in the period 2006 to 2008 the answer is
down 82% so you know this is a pretty
big change and so a question that Frank
and Henrik and I have been exploring is
did anybody notice this so by the way
there are now 900 funds because 450
really wouldn't do so and one of those
900 funds is identical to the default
fund but has no leverage so it was
possible if you liked the thing you were
in and these guys in the room and I know
who you are who claim they picked the
default fund by choice in their wisdom
I'm looking at you pear presumably they
were picking an unlevered fund and you
know might have noticed that this thing
has gotten a lot of risk maybe I should
switch into this other fund that's just
like the one I
allegedly actively picked so did anyone
notice so here's a plot of the leverage
over time this is the number of people
that were leaving the default fund I
don't know whether you can read those
numbers the scale goes from 0 to 400
maybe up to 600 there are 3 million
investors in this fund so our conclusion
is we cannot reject the hypothesis that
3 million Swedish investors are asleep
they may be asleep we cannot rule that
out they certainly are not deserting the
fund in droves so what can we conclude
from this
the first is nudges can be quite
powerful
both the nudge of creating a default
which has recently been all powerful and
the earlier nudge saying please don't
take the default that was also very
powerful second and this we've never
been able to test before Thank You
Sweden for giving us this opportunity we
now know nudges can last at least 17
years possibly longer and it's
suggesting a new marketing campaign for
our nudging efforts
so let me conclude it is possible many
people told me early on it's just not
possible to do economics any other way
it wouldn't be economics so that's not
true it's possible to do economics
without homo economics sorry
second if we learn from other social
scientists we can improve economics we
can increase its explanatory power and
it can give us all kinds of new tools
that we can use to improve people's
outcomes so in short we can nudge for
good
thank you
[Applause]